here's what would happen if you lived on  Uranus well first you'd experience one  of the stinkiest atmospheres in our  solar system Uranus is gassy made up of  hydrogen helium and methane the high  altitudes would be the smelliest you'd  experience a rotten egg smell from all  the hydrogen sulfide Uranus doesn't have  a true surface it's made of slushy water  methane and ammonia fluids above a small  rocky Center and you couldn't see much  since Uranus only receives about 0.27  percent as much sunlight as Earth  because of the low light you couldn't  grow food you'd need to bring it on your  spaceship temperatures on Uranus drop as  low as minus 225 degrees and you would  face massive clouds of ammonia methane  ice crystals and wind storms your best  bet to survive here would be on a  floating settlement high in the clouds  so